got some Germans and the chats gather
Norwegian still firm Germany yeah people
were saying where they were from this
morning like streams I streamed like
five six hours ago
so I'm assuming people haven't changed
locations at least so returning viewers
okay let's play d5 let's play double
Queen's pawn I have to sneeze but I
can't sneeze I'm bad at sneezing when
like there's a spotlight on me just too
much pressure
Patrick JMT what's up even more pressure
now shout-out to Patrick Jane MT I don't
think I can shout out why were the
shadow command doesn't work for like a
youtube channel only works for a twitch
channel alright Knight c3 trying to
think of some creative stuff I'm just
gonna stick with my my usual repertoire
look at the lights light is right in
front of me always looking at it
pretty much maybe I'll transpose into a
Cambridge strings I'll start with this
move Knight B to d7 cuz it comes with a
trap my opponent is lower than low rated
enough where he might fall for it
the trap is after takes takes it looks
like white can grab a pawn Lord
Francisco with bits
thanks for the 200 bits takes takes
takes is not happening if it works
happen I would temporarily sack a queen
and then win it back with I should be
four and win a piece just flow with the
result
for three months so I'm trying to
achieve a Cambridge Springs which is
actually a fun opening yeah we're gonna
have the mean position Queen a5 this is
the start of the Cambridge Springs idea
that Queen a5 pressure the this diagonal
and also some sneaky ideas of
punishing the bishop on g5 and very
often black will combine 94 in Bishop
before it's been a while since I played
this I the coach who taught it to me
many years ago probably when I was like
11 or 12 years old Bishop d3 is a
mistake Bishop d3 walks into issues
actually trying to remember 94 ticks I
think I'm supposed to take first I've
taught this to a lot of students to this
simple simple line against the Queen's
Gambit after Bishop takes 94 will be a
fourth the Queen and the night will
coordinates to attack both the bishop
and the Knights and black should win
upon whoa okay maybe my opponents wonder
if my opponents watching most people
just automatically take back yeah maybe
wakes the spot there's white surviving
this huh I could try and hold on to the
d3 pawn that's slightly irritating yeah
let's try and hold on to the d3 pawn
it's a weird situation the bishop will
have have to save itself and then I have
a move like Queen a6
it depends where the bishop goes it
should be 5 mm don't underestimate the
cake bagel I didn't even realize my
pawns using it that sounds delicious
a cake bagel
[Music]
cake bagel okay let's focus on moves I
could take the bishop and get the bishop
hair but then whites easily winning the
pawn I could play queen a6 looking to
set up traps I'm imagining white takes
and then like I get two moves in a row
like b6 Bishop a6 maybe I'll just play
queen a6 simple enough good morning just
a blue happy belated birthday
even though I wish you Earth Day on your
actual birthday guess now it's your
belated birthday good to see that you're
alive what to do this bishop is very
depressed I could play C 5 C 5 is
interesting actually I'm gonna play C 5
idea is if takes my knight can come in
defend the pawn otherwise maybe c4 and
I'll have some weird pawn chain in
White's territory Joe Bruin what's up
good to see you Joe brew and everyone
else why didn't say hello to hello to
everyone else if you could bring only
one chess book to a desert island spend
next 10 years
one chess book oh that's rough I mean
probably the the loss loophole car 5230
for how many problems it's over five
thousand problems and a lot of them are
like difficult like made in twos or made
in threes so that would maybe keep me
entertained I got that book when I was
like eight or nine and was like working
through it for a good like six to seven
years I don't think I completed it but I
solved like most of the mating problems
singing that saggy naggy asking to
streams in one day there might actually
be three streams in one
it's looking likely I'll be doing a KU
stream tonight with another chest
streamer takes takes c4 and then B five
and a six not all in Connect four
okay let's take a quick I could also
play b5 here hmm
c4 it looks fine this is so unusual
cuz I just it's like my D pawn like
cheated and jumped over the white steep
on in reality I just captured twice
let's play b5 actually I don't have to
play b5 because White's not really
threatening to take but I'll do it
anyway just to show my Dominus
it might has to move back and then a6
I'm hoping Connect four
yeah I've been showing students at
Cambridge Springs for years I've been
playing it myself but never actually
encountering this like intermezzo like
this ship takes off six but perhaps this
is one reason why white should still
have weighed this line my bishop will
find happiness the winter is over
springtime is coming I could still take
this bishop in probably any time
Wow b3 III allows b4 c3d - this seems
too good to be true like I haven't
developed like these pieces I'm just
pushing pawns on the Queen side I have
to do it
I mean tonight's gonna move c3 nothing's
hitting the D pawn and then D - I'll
have a pawn chain leading up so late
second drink I guess maybe I could sack
but I'll be happy to in the Knights cake
bagel is tasting very delicious so far I
need to connect four emotes that's true
okay c3 time yeah no need to take this
bishop at least yet d2 coming and then
a5 and I'll win Connect four again but
on the dark space
the Knights actually very restricted
like I'm controlling all these squares
then I can move - we might see a 3 a 3
that's it's nice that I have an a pawn -
just to reinforce everything after D to
mean if the rook like ideas of D - C -
could come very soon this needs to go on
YouTube yeah shout out to the future
YouTube people watching hope you're
being entertained
now this really doesn't happen every day
I need to play more chess so maybe it'll
happen every other day or maybe I'll
just retire after this game
quit chess and take up take up cooking
learn how to make a cake bagel I really
don't know what light does here there's
white wants to like undermine the pollen
somehow but there's so few resources
like a three is a resource and okay
there's moves to attack the D pawn but
d2 will come so sacking is it's logical
it kind of makes me sad that I'm losing
my my beautiful pawns but that's the
circle of life now I think the strategy
is just to trade everything oh I could
set up a trap I could play a five and
maybe actually I hold on to the D pawn
my tactics yeah I'll play a five white
still has to work to win the pawn okay
both rooks could attack the pawn but the
bishop will defend the pawn if I play
Bishop a6 and I'll play Bishop b4 remove
this rook maybe d2 someday so this pawn
is it's been surviving it landed on d3
on move eight what a survivor Raph
Raqqah welcome back do you have a day
job my day job is pushing pawns and
receiving bits and subs dude one one
four thanks for subbing yeah so the
bishop defends if ninety one it attacks
a pawn that walks into a fork it's a
problem whenever like a pawn is close to
promoting yes in this case White has to
be very very careful like every move to
check if d2 works for me
another sub Nicola Sturgeon subbing for
8 months
and dude subbing for for 7 months some
nice streaks
yeah so light has a single pawn for the
minor piece a really no compensation
does have the C file I control CH so
that's important
my considered Bishop e3 next just remove
the rook and then there should be four
remove the other rook or just wait for
white to flag I don't want to play d2
too soon like even if I play Bishop b4
rook C 72 it could be over pushing but
maybe I would have Bishop e2 in the end
but then whose rook c8 I have to have to
calculate ya and shout-out to the
European viewers I think this is still
you friendly it should be like evening
in Europe
what like 9 or 10 p.m. or you call it
what it's like what do you call it 20 20
or 21 hour does you use military time
woah using goats continuing the sub that
they got from mataji I'm John Davis
thanks gazing goats
I don't think Bishop d7 was better it is
a long diagonal but I wanted to defend
the pawn so rook c6
this is tricky because if I develop the
bishop then there's this move and then
there's this move I could lose a rook if
I'm not careful it was very sneaky
another sub-b Zach I'm contemplating
just sacking this rook commend but it's
probably not the best decision and
Brooksie six is actually a good move
thinking I can take I mean I just want
to simplify so takes takes D to work t1
and Bishop b4 and threatening Bishop e2
that's hard to stop
there's night C for this is good enough
I'll take
yeah the Bishop's Lisa last bishop will
come to life
whoa okay I can take with check move
surprised me for a moment there but now
I'm a bishop and a rook for a pawn oh no
I'm losing my d3 pawn oh no I'm not good
game
oh that's nice finished I'll put that on
YouTube
the fook seer thanks for subbing oh
gifted by just a blue thanks just a blue
sure the gift sub gifting 67 subs yeah
so if you're watching on YouTube you can
also subscribe for free on YouTube
or you can subscribe on Twitch with
twitch prime or or for half price
because it's September
but yeah I'm wrapping it up for the each
of audience hope you enjoyed that hope
you're inspired to push pawns Nicola
Sturgeon 1000 bonus 100
thanks for the subway bits and YouTube
people I'll see you in the future